[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau journal as
d'informations locales nous sommes le
mercredi 11 mai au sommaire aujourd'hui
les épreuves du baccalauréat sont lancés
depuis ce mercredi 11 mai et jusqu'à
vendredi les élèves de terminale
plancheront sur leurs épreuves écrites
d'enseignement de spécialité nous serons
en duplex depuis le lycée louis de
broglie à marly-le-roi établissement où
s'est rendu pour l'occasion jean michel
blanquer ministre de l'éducation
nationale malgré la reprise économique
et le phénomène d'inflation de
nombreuses entreprises peinent à trouver
des employés à quels sont les métiers en
tension et pourquoi n'arrive t il pas à
recruter à des entreprises iv noises à
nouveau ouvert leurs portes et puis le
groupe kyo et de retour là où tout a
commencé à verneuil sur seine cette
année marque leurs 20 ans de carrière et
pour fêter l'événement un concert
anniversaire est prévue le 25 juin
prochain nous les avons rencontrés en
avant première
[Musique]
et je vous le disais en titre les
épreuves du baccalauréat sont lancées à
ce mac os 10 les élèves de terminale ont
débuté leur épreuve de spécialité et
pour l'occasion jean michel blanquer re
s'est rendu dans les yvelines au lycée
louis de broglie à marly-le-roi sans
doute son dernier déplacement dans le
cadre de ses fonctions de ministre de
l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse et
des sports on retrouve sur place
mathilde de franck où
effectivement justin je me trouve au
lycée louis de breuil à marly-le-roi
pour le coup d'envoi des premières
épreuves écrites de spécialités du
baccalauréat général et technologique
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
jean michel blanquer est arrivé il y à
quelques minutes pour aller à la
rencontre des élèves après les deux ans
de kovy 19 c'est la première fois depuis
la réforme du bac que ces nouvelles
épreuves de spécialité ont eu lieu alors
ces épreuves quelles sont elles il
s'agit des deux matières choisies par
les élèves comme géopolitique sciences
politiques ou encore humanité
littérature philosophie ces disciplines
donne ensuite une orientation à leur
parcours scolaire en fonction de la
spécialité choisie il peut s'agir d'un
examen écrit ou pratiques comme pour la
physique chimie pour les spécialités
artistiques comme la musique le théâtre
ou le cinéma les élèves devront passer
une partie écrite et une partie orale
chacune de ces épreuves dispose d'un
coefficient 16 en france c'est 5 123
mille candidats qui vont passer leurs
nouvelles spécialités jusqu'au vendredi
13 mai et ses thématiques de francs coup
avec célia gars tsongo aux moyens
techniques avec la reprise économique et
malgré le phénomène d'inflation de
nombreuses entreprises rencontrent des
problèmes de recrutement entre les
difficultés à trouver à des profils
compétents l'importance de la demande
d'emploi dans plusieurs secteurs et puis
le phénomène de grandes émissions les
sociétés tentent de trouver des
solutions pour faire face un sujet que
nous allons approfondir avec vous à
philippe campe bonsoir bonsoir avec nous
vous êtes le directeur territorial pôle
emploi dont pour les yvelines pour
commencer à ce qu'on peut faire déjà
peut être un point sur les secteurs en
tension aujourd'hui oui alors les
secteurs en tension sur sur l'île de
france mais aussi sur le département il
ya huit secteurs aujourd'hui qui sont en
tension on à l'industrie on à
l'hôtellerie restauration
on a le bâtiment lettres le transport
logistique on a le numérique aussi la
santé l'action sociale
et puis la sécurité le commerce ça ce
sont des secteurs qui reviennent chaque
année on a vu une certaine évolution
dans les années précédentes alors il ya
des évolutions par exemple l'hôtellerie
restauration qui c'est qui s'est
dégradée avec l'effet de la crise
sanitaire puisqu'il ya aussi un certain
nombre de salariés qui ont quitté leur
emploi et 10 qui donc ont aggravé la
situation de pénurie de main-d'oeuvre
qu'on pouvait connaître par le par le
passé mais qui dans dans une mesure
encore beaucoup plus importante
aujourd'hui justement avant de
poursuivre notre entretien je vous
propose de découvrir finalement
l'exemple de deux secteurs qui ont du
mal à recruter ce sont une société
d'informatique à versailles est une
entreprise industrielle de montigny le
bretonneux c'est un reportage de nicolas
attendri et célia gars de son goût
regarder alors vous m'avez adresser
votre candidature car vous recherchez un
stage c'est ça un stage de deux mois
dans la cybersécurité un profil qui
tombe au bon moment le dirigeant de
cette entreprise informatique de
versailles cherche à recruter
actuellement 10 nouveaux collaborateurs
ingénieurs techniciens mais aussi
commerciaux dans la maintenance et la
sécurité informatique
ce stagiaire pour l enrichir ses équipes
même poursuivre en alternance est allé
jusqu'à signer un cdi et le bilan de
l'entretien semble être positif
la juge leys remplir un test technique
mais je pense qu on l'acceptera et on va
l'intégrer on va le former on va le
faire grandir fait agrandir des jeunes
stagiaires à une solution pour faire
face aux difficultés de recrutement
notamment dans le secteur du numérique
mais les entreprises doivent est encore
allé plus loin il ya beaucoup de monde
un secteur qui est très dynamique et
effectivement on peine à recruter
aujourd'hui à trouver des ressources
formés et disponibles en plus une
rémunération intéressante nos candidats
la plupart auront à leur disposition un
véhicule une mutuelle intéressant des
tickets restaurant où on est au maximum
du plafond du plafond légal la possible
de participer aussi à l'événement
sportif plusieurs fois dans l'année
entièrement pris en charge par le groupe
ce phénomène de difficultés de
recrutement concerne de nombreux
secteurs économiques plus complexe
encore pour les activités de niche à
forte technicité
c'est le cas de cette entreprise
industrielle spécialisée dans la
fabrication de prototypes de recherche
et développement elle recherche
actuellement quatre nouveaux
collaborateurs on essaye d'avoir des
entretiens mais c'est pas assez pas
évident parce que bon bah en soit en ce
moment il ya une forte une forte demande
certains jeunes ne voient pas forcément
l'industrie dans leur coeur pour pour
pour travailler les écoles techniques
sont moins en moins à former des jeunes
et c'est pas évident de trouver de bons
profils ou des gens qu'il ya aussi les
gens qui veulent continuer à ces
difficultés vient s'ajouter un phénomène
engendré par la crise sanitaire la
grande démission le fait pour des
collaborateurs de démissionner et de se
reconvertir dans une nouvelle activité
alors du coup philippe quand on a vu ce
reportage avec ces exemples nous avait
également donné des exemples de secteurs
en tension pourquoi ces métiers
aujourd'hui n'arrive pas à recruter ce
qu'il ya un manque de postulants un
manque de connaissance que c'est dû à
quoi en fait plusieurs choses il ya déjà
la reprise économique qui est présente
et il ya une baisse de la demande
d'emploi
si on regarde un peu les chiffres du
chômage au premier trimestre 2009 22 on
est à 65 milles 20 64 mille demandeurs
d'emploi en catégorie a dont qui n'ont
jamais travaillé donc on est une baisse
de 4,1 pour cent depuis le premier
trimestre et on est sur une baisse de 12
4% sur sur une année donc forcément les
deux conjugués s'attend un peu le temps
un peu le marché
après effectivement
nous avons
une difficulté avec les employeurs c'est
avec les employeurs sont restés sur un
mode de recrutement qu'ils avaient
l'habitude d'effectuer aujourd'hui face
à cette pénurie il faut certainement
adapter sa méthode et aujourd'hui on a
peut-être parmi nos demandeurs d'emploi
des personnes qui n'ont pas forcément
toutes les compétences mais qui peuvent
les acquérir au travers de mesures
d'adaptation qu'on peut proposer aux
entreprises donc ce sont des
déformations jusqu'à 400 heures que nous
payons et une fois que l'information est
effectuée l'entreprise peut recruter ce
futur salarié qui a du coup de
développer les compétences nécessaires
pour tenir le poste donc il faut pas
chercher le candidat idéal mais chercher
le candidat qui s'en rapproche le plus
et donc du coup nous pouvons aider des
entreprises à former leurs candidats et
surtout à payer de la formation on a
aussi la méthode de recrutement par
simulation qui permet de au travers
d'exercices de juger des habilités d'un
candidat et du coup d'identifier des
complets les compétences de ce candidat
est tout à leur veulent dans votre
reportage vous parliez de l'industrie là
je vais vous parler de l'entreprise
c'est le maire qui est sûre sûrement
donc qui fabrique des des saxos et des
clarinettes et on a travaillé avec cette
entreprise pour effectivement recrutés
au travers de la méthode de recrutement
de simulation et ils ont pu recruter 7 7
collaborateurs donc ça ce sont des
solutions que vous pouvez apporter aux
entreprises en tout cas pour accompagner
de deux nouveaux employés finalement
tout à fait exactement du coup je
voulais revenir aussi sur on l'a vu cet
exemple dans le reportage sur les
difficultés de recrutement dans le
secteur du numérique parce que
finalement c'est un secteur un peu
nouveau si je puis dire les entreprises
ont beaucoup de demandes d'emploi mais
des fois fondement que font face à un
manque de compétences en vous en avez
parlé tout à l'heure justement pour
répondre à ces difficultés vous faites
aussi des formations par exemple dans le
numérique alors on a des formations dans
numérique ont parlé de la cybersécurité
dans le reportage effectivement les
formations à la cybersécurité donc on
utilise les formations qui sont financés
par le conseil régional ile de france ou
qui sont financés par par pôle emploi
aujourd'hui nous avons à notre
disposition et à la disposition des
entreprises beaucoup de formations qui
pourront leur permettre de recruter
leurs futurs leurs futurs salariés
d'accord très bien et par exemple pour
les demandeurs d'emploi qui viennent
vous voir là aussi vous pour les
accompagner s'ils veulent eux qui font
pas partie des entreprises qui n'ont pas
possible en entreprise mais ce que pour
les banier pour acquérir des compétences
justement tout à fait d'ailleurs dans
nos agences dans les onze agences du
département nous organisations nous
organisons des événements alors soit des
job dating pour de recrutement soit de
la découverte de métiers et du coup en
fonction en fonction de leurs hôtes de
leurs de leur souhait on peut les
orienter sur des formations au regard
des métiers qu'ils veulent qu'ils
veulent faire je voudrais rebondir sur
on en parlait en début d'entretien ce
phénomène dit de grandes démission qui
vient un peu des etats-unis est-ce que
vous avez l'impression que ça ça arrive
dans les yvelines par exemple je pense
que personne n'était pas renié les
yvelines comme les autres départements
de france ou d'île de france sont
concernés en fait donc ça on peut voir
cesser par rapport plutôt à la crise
humnaitaire vous c'est la génération un
petit peu qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on a
envie de donner un sens ajustements à
notre métier à notre profession je pense
que les deux la crise sanitaire et
effectivement les nouveaux salariés qui
rentrent sur le marché du travail ont
certainement une approche tout à fait
différente de celle de des personnes qui
sont actuellement en poste aujourd'hui
quand une certaine ancienneté est ce que
vous vous êtes confrontés parfois
justement à des personnes comme ça qui
sont en quête de sens dans leur travail
et comment vous faites pour les
accompagner justement m c'est le rôle
des conseillers a de travailler le
projet professionnel de savoir
exactement ce qu'ils qu'ils veulent ce
qu'ils sont qu'à ce qu'ils sont capables
d'accepter de ne pas accepter voilà
c'est vraiment le travail de relations
humaines avec avec le demandeur d'emploi
lorsqu'il est en fait de son de son
conseiller j'aurais peut-être faire un
point avec vous à savoir s'il ya des
dates à venir notamment par rapport à sa
part rapport comment trouver un emploi
comment être accompagnés et puis sinon
comment on peut faire justement si on
est dans ce cas là on a une entreprise
qui peine à recruter est-ce qu'on peut
venir vous voir quand comment comment ça
se passe l'entreprise peut se déplacer
dans l'est dans les agences du
département mais tu es appelé aussi le
39 95 donc un numéro court et qui va la
mettre en relation avec un conseiller en
entreprise jusque dans chaque agence
aujourd'hui nous avons des conseillers
dédiés à l'entreprise qui sont capables
de parler du marché du travail des
rémunérations qui sont qui sont proposés
dans sur tel ou tel métier pour aussi
que l'employeur puisse se jauger par
rapport par rapport à ça
nous avons aussi effectivement des
événements on a organisé au mois de
d'avril du stade vers l'emploi qui est
aussi une autre méthode de recrutement
puisque là en fait le matin on est sur
des épreuves sportives donc sur montigny
le bretonneux on était sûrs du rugby et
là les candidats et les recruteurs sont
mélangés personne ne sait qui est qui et
qui et puis l'après midi on passe bas au
recrutement ce qui a permis aussi aux
recruteurs dans le cadre de l'activité
sportive de commencer à
évaluer les candidats puis après on
passe sur un job dating plus plus
classique et le 17 mai avec la ligue
d'athlétisme sur saint germain en laye
nous avons donc le même type d'exercice
à ce qu'un événement qu'on appelle du
stade vers le vers l'emploi qui lui sera
à venir en tout cas pour pour l'autre
date on l'avait couvert justement si des
personnes veulent se renseigner à leurs
reportages et est disponible sur tv 78
et on verra dernier évènement aussi le
30 mai l'éducation nationale recherche
aussi beaucoup de personnel que ça soit
des professeurs des écoles des
professeurs du second degré des
infirmiers des médecins
des accompagnants d'élèves aussi et donc
le 30 mai il y aura un job dating au
rectorat de versailles avec de nombreux
postes à pourvoir c'est noté merci
beaucoup pour ces informations 1
philippe quand je le rappelle un vous
êtes le directeur territorial donc pour
les yvelines de pôle emploi merci
beaucoup merci de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
en politique à présent un point sur les
élections législatives 2022 on connaît
désormais les candidats du rassemblement
national qui sont investis dans les
yvelines parmi eux on retrouve mathilde
et andrew et pour la 5e circonscription
la députée européenne qui a joué un rôle
majeur dans la campagne de marine le pen
on a également civile note ex maire de
mantes la ville ce sera pour la 8ème
circonscription ou encore le
représentant départemental du
rassemblement national laurent morin
pour la 9e circonscription
dans le reste de l'actualité après un
premier essai l'année dernière avec à
quatre collèges yvelinois le département
des yvelines lance officiellement son
premier concours d'éloquence ce sera le
mardi prochain 14 établissements ont
débattu donc c'était mardi 10 mai par
dont quatorze établissements ont débattu
sur les réseaux sociaux est-ce qu'ils
nous rendent heureux ou malheureux et
son team une source d'information les
explications de mathilde de franck ou
sous forme de joutes oratoires ou plus
au calme en défendant son discours
individuellement ils étaient une
trentaine de collégiens argumenté sur
les réseaux sociaux initié par le
département des yvelines ce concours
d'éloquence avait de multiples objectifs
je trouve que c'est très important
d'abord ils vont en avoir besoin dans le
cadre de leur examen et puis dans
l'autre critère même dans leurs études
moi j'ai trouvé en tout cas ce que j'ai
pu voir aujourd'hui les prestations
extraordinaires des jeunes de 3e à voir
je dirais une une éloquence comme celle
ci une aisance sur le plateau face alors
à leurs camarades et on voit qu'il ya un
travail de fond je crois que c'est
fondamental aujourd'hui de redonner la
place à la parole à l'expression et à la
confiance dans soit il estime de soi
aussi de type d'exercice était proposé
un argumentaire et un duel et les élèves
étaient évalués par un jury composé de
trois personnes une journaliste une
avocate est un artiste c'est intéressant
parce qu'il se confronte à
l'argumentation à comment poser son avis
on voit aussi qu'ils sont la
confrontation de l'ecoute cercle comment
on s'écoute et comme on écoute les
arguments des uns des autres alors quand
on sait en solo si nice et c'est plus
simple quand c'est en duo c'est plus
compliqué alors on a effectivement une
grille de notation
ensuite on évalue justement les ans les
le fond les postures l'interaction avec
le public puisque tout ça en fait forme
un tout autre but développer sa
confiance en soi pas facile devant une
salle comble de 400 collégiens au début
j'étais un peu stressé je vous avoue
tout mais au fil du temps dès que je
suis arrivé sur scène et que j'ai
commencé à parler je trouve que je
trouvais que ça allait bien j'avais un
peu le public avec moi je sais pas si
c'est vrai mais voilà ça m'a donné de la
confiance même si j'ai pas réussi à
placer tous les arguments mon adversaire
était très bon il faut l'avouer j'ai eu
le cd pas mon objectif de base de gagné
et j'étais très fier de moi c'est
impressionnant ces deux-là profac
janzéens et et non très bonne ambiance
ce qui ce qui nous ont aidés pendant six
mois étaient géniaux une bonne mentalité
dans ce terreau monde hyper enrichissant
plus trois trophées ont été remis à
l'issue du concours le trophée du
meilleur éloquent pour l'argumentaire le
trophée du meilleur éloquente pour le
duel est un dernier trophée pour
l'établissement qui a comptabilisé le
plus de points tout au long du concours
côté culturel est de retour la nuit des
musées se déroulera le samedi 14 mai
2022 de multiples événements sont prévus
cette année dont de nombreux lieux
culturels yvelinois le musée de la ville
et la médiathèque du canal ont préparé
une programmation originale pour
l'occasion céline charles vous détaille
le programme
[Musique]
vous
un autre retour le 25 juin dans les
yvelines après attend de semin parcouru
le groupe qui ont révélé dans les années
2000 sera en concert à verneuil sur
seine là où tout a commencé notre
journaliste michael mier d'euros a pu
les rencontrer je vous propose un
extrait de notre émission v yt vous les
avez reconnus c'est qui au bonjour
messieurs bonjour message benoît nicolas
florian et et jocelyn alors on est chez
vous ici à verneuil-sur-seine vous allez
revenir pour un grand concert qui sont
organisées le 25 juin prochain au parc
du château notre dame les oiseaux alors
qu'est ce que ça vous fait messieurs le
droit peut-être ben c'est beaucoup
beaucoup d'émotion c'est vrai que on en
parlait en fait
ça fait longtemps qu'on parle de cette
idée et
le fait que ça se réalise enfin
en plus ça se réalise à un moment où
nous on a on a repris la tournée après
deux ans de frustration que ce soit pour
le public ou pour nous de ne pas avoir
pu jouer donc ça fait
aussi 20 ans que le groupe existe donc
tout ça est assez symbolique en fait et
ouais je sais pas à re découvrir
l'endroit parce que même si on a de la
famille sûr dans les environs dont
convient dans la région mais attendez de
la famille dans le coin dreamin ouais
mais assez vrai que moi j'ai pas mis les
pieds dans l'enceinte de l'établissement
depuis plus de vingt ans donc forcément
ça hyper à nouveau et ça fait quoi
justement à venir ici basse et c'est
plein de souvenirs en forcément qui
remonte à la surface on sert on sait
tous rencontrés avec flo plutôt dans le
coin là bas des maternelles avec ben
juste à côté donc c'est vrai que tout ça
revient et c'est vrai qu'en plus mais on
n'était pas enfin moi je sais que
j'étais pas sûr que l'école puisse
organiser un concert de cette taille là
dans l'enceinte de l'établissement parce
que bon c'est quand même beaucoup de
beaucoup de monde donc ça c'est vraiment
super que qu'ils aient pu organiser ça
donc c'était en 1994 c'est bien ça que
vous êtes trop près bah on s'est
rencontré avec the way avec flo on s'est
rencontré en très tôt à
allez à quoi je devrais ans 12-13 ans
donc en 92 ouais à peu près et on sait
mais on était aussi à maternelle ici
donc
nico était dans la même classe que mon
grand frère déjà à quatre ans dont
quatre au canada mais on n'avait pas
commencé à faire un groupe encore et
ouais on sait comment contrer les
retraites je devais avoir 12 13 ans et
le rock c'était l'évidence pour vous
tout de suite alors c'est ce qu'on
écoute à l'époque je pense que c'est ça
qui nous a réuni aussi on avait vingt
dix ans tous les deux on a preneur mais
ouais ou qu'il fallait les trucs de
genre lingen ce nirvana red hot chili
peppers comme ça de l'époque 2003 où
vous êtes produit pour la première fois
ici dans les yvelines pour un concert au
complexe sportif françois pons de
verneuil est-ce que vous en souvenez
vous pas du tout voici parce que c'est
quand même ça fait partie des tous
premiers conserve donc on s'en souvient
il était comment ce concert justement là
qu'on avait approché justement l'idée de
revenir jouer dans le coin mais sans
jamais vraiment imaginer qu'on pourrait
se mettre dans le parquet ait joué là où
je faisais du foot
j'avais 8 ans quoi je me sens les
personnes qui seront denses et ce à quoi
le plus j'avais imaginé t on pourrait
mettre la scène ici et tout bois sagem
est faisable pour des raisons de
sécurité et tout ça comme nico mais là
si ça respire un peu fou est ce qu'on
réalisait ou pas du tout
depuis demain déjà depuis qu'on est
arrivé dans la rue a juste avant là ça
commence à réaliser un peu plus qu elle
en a revu des têtes de profs qu'on
n'avait pas vu savait pas s'il y aurait
des preuves qu'on comprend qu'on avait
eu ou pas quoi mais il ya eu des bonnes
surprises et donc c'est si je commence à
réaliser un peu est ce que ça vous met
un peu la pression justement ce concert
le succès dans un lieu où vous
connaissez a particulièrement bien
ça aurait été un premier concert de
tourner je pense qu'on aurait carrément
la pression mais là
la shdm tous les shows qu'on a fait pour
l'instant sont hyper bien passé donc on
est là c'est assez serein je pense qu'au
contraire ça va être ça va être quelque
chose en plus tu vois ça va être
je pense que le show il rôdait donc ça
nous il n'y a pas de problème mais
mais on va nous vivre une émotion
particulière évidemment par rapport aux
autres aux autres dates donc voilà on a
super hot vous allez faire quelque chose
de particulier ou pas pour cette date je
sais pas ce qu'ils lisent surprise ou
est-ce qu'il faut pas trop en parler
mais évidemment la surprise je t'avoue
qu'on en a pas quand vous discutez pas
encore hélas tu viens de faire réaliser
qu effectivement c'est bien c'est une
bonne chose merci à vous et bon concert
le 25 juin prochain ce sera ici là où
tout a commencé à verneuil sur seine le
concert commencera à 21h
émission complète à retrouver assure tv
78 c'est la fin de ce journal merci à
tous de nous avoir suivis prenez soin de
vous et à très vite sur télé 78
[Musique]